[Musique]
bon maintenant de regarder ensemble un
reportage qui est le résultat d'une
enquête une enquête sur l' influence des
jeux vidéo sur les enfants influencent
ou effets bénéfiques effets négatifs
regardez cette enquête de michele pirro
abracadabra le sujet va venir vous allez
voir la mâchoire et crispé le regard
fixe les gestes saccadés
les symptômes sont clairs le diagnostic
sans appel
ces enfants sont atteints d'un mal très
contemporain la passion des jeux vidéo
deux cent quarante mille consoles
vendues l'année dernière en france après
les états unis l'angleterre et
l'allemagne
nous sommes donc atteinte nous aussi par
cette épidémie un mal qui répand la
terreur parmi certains éducateurs et
parents
il aime bien quoi
mon père lui reste indifférent mais ma
mère à londres a par ailleurs parce que
ça fait beaucoup de bruit ce qui est
bien c'est la difficulté puis si
difficile pu mieux plus c'est marrant
des coûts beaucoup de choses je connais
pas et c'est
toute façon c'est moderne ou s'amuser de
détails
quand ça bouge plus parce qu'alors je
dors affectionne
un moment commence un peu ça commence un
peu est énervant sinon c'est bien
[Musique]
on
les jours
avec ça
[Musique]
m
qu'est-ce qui dansent et je peux à ce
point solliciter leur intérêt et leur
attention
une enquête de la sofres réalisée auprès
de 250 enfants de 7 à 14 ans nous
apprend que la majorité d'entre eux est
m ainsi projetés dans un autre univers
surmonter les difficultés et surtout
réalisé des performances toujours
supérieure avec jeux vidéo ils sont ils
participent et il participe avec
patients il ya une espèce de compétition
avec soi-même ils veulent se vaincre
même ils veulent gagner ils veulent
réussir et à partir du moment où un
enfant veut réussir
évidemment il ya un dynamisme absolument
extraordinaires qui se fit qui existent
en lui et je trouve que c'est excellent
qui peut être dangereux dans ces jeux
c'est le fait que ça se joue avec un
écran très près du visage
alors là effectivement au bout d'une
heure de jeu les enfants peuvent avoir
souffrir déçus sinon ces jeux sont très
intéressants et très amusant pour les
enfants
nous autres adultes on n'est pas habitué
à ce type de jeu alors on les regarde
d'une certaine façon mais pour l'enfant
c'est quelque chose de naturel de normal
ça fait partie du monde qui l'entourent
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'ils le
comprennent qu'ils le connaissent et je
crois qu'il adapte bien dans sa vie il
ne lui accorde pas trop d'importance
pour lui c'est la même chose que de
jouer aux cow-boys dehors il y apporte à
temps il je crois que l'enfant une
attitude serait beaucoup plus
raisonnable que la ducasse aujourd'hui
au jury de haut
alors si certains adultes inquiète
autant de ce phénomène
ne serait ce pas en réalité de peur
d'être surpassé par leurs propres
enfants
[Musique]